la actual constitución
se escribió para salir de un régimen de autoritario
y entrar a un régimen democrático
fue ratificada el año 89
después de un acuerdo
entre todas las fuerzas políticas
menos aquellos que no les gusta la democracia
con un 93% de la población
ahora se continuaron las reformas 240
y tantas reformas del año 2005
se establece y celebra
entonces toda la centro izquierda
que la actual constitución
ya no sería la constitución de pinochet
pero posteriormente aparecen ciertos movimientos
especialmente dentro de nuestra clase política
que a su fracaso
su fracaso
administrando este país y entregándole a la gente
los servicios sociales que corresponden
de acuerdo con los impuestos que pagan
le echan la culpa
entonces al empedrado dicen que no es culpa de ustedes
que la administración de fonasa sea una porquería
que las pensiones no suba no es su culpa
culpa es de la constitución siempre la constitución
nunca es un problema
de aquellos que están sentados en esta sala
que estaban sentados en la moneda
ese ha sido el discurso permanente de excusa
con el cual ustedes han
confundido a la población
respecto a las responsabilidades
que caen sobre sus propios pies
respecto a la mala administración del estado
las últimas décadas
y ahora todo el mundo dice cómo cambiar la constitución
bajemos los cobros
eso es el resultado del miedo al violentismo turista
que sigue instalado aquí
que sigue instalado aquí aquí
que va a ser siempre antidemocrático que ahora
aparte de ser antidemocrático ha incluido
elementos racistas en lo que es su propuesta
de chile
vamos
está acostumbrado a arrancar derrotas de las fauces
de la victoria
chile no quiere la nueva constitución
que ha propuesto
aquellos que no creen en la democracia
que no creen en la igualdad del voto
aquellos que no creen que todos los chilenos
independientes
nuestra etnia
somos iguales
chile no lo quiere y no va a votar a favor de ello
y sin embargo
ahora ponemos a disposición
la constitución
incluso en aquellas temas más delicados
como son los derechos humanos
este tema
de los 4 séptimos era absolutamente innecesario
como era también innecesario
cambiar la constitución bastaba con hacer bien la pega
muchas gracias